some exciting news from number 10 and it
seems something of a tradition now to
have babies when a prime minister yes so
we have just had this statement release
to us as you say the Prime Minister and
Miss Simmons are very pleased to
announce their engagement and that they
are expecting a baby in the early summer
Kari Simmons the girlfriend of Boris
Johnson who has moved into Downing
Street alongside him spent time at
Chequers and other areas where they are
understood to be this weekend confirming
that they are expecting a baby and that
they are now engaged to be married we
don't know as yet when the marriage
would be whether it would be before the
baby is due in early summer or whether
it be at a later point so this is very
early stages we were just getting this
statement through from Downing Street
Boris Johnson of course has four
children with his former wife marina
wheeler who he has separated from
recently although they have not been
together for some time he also has a
fifth child with the art dealer
Helen McIntyre and there has been of
course questions about other children
and at the suggestions that he has never
engaged with and that we do not don't
have any further information on but this
news will be that Boris Johnson and his
partner Keri Simmons will be expecting a
baby in the early summer
you